today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza in gray block pizza if
you want that you want that beautiful
taste you want that something you want
something to hit your lips and get
inside of your lips in your face and you
want it to be pizza they got you 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
in Los Angeles gray block get that
hitter today's guests I've been a fan of
for a long time
he won an NBA championship in his rookie
year with the Boston Celtics he played
in a Final Four with LSU Tigers and and
he's as entertaining as they come he's
one half of the hosts ship of the new
podcast the rabbit and the bear it is
mr. Glen big baby Davis
[Music]
you let the star to start when you left
Louisiana did you have dinner
the food is is not the same yeah but you
know what I mean I felt like well we're
from it's just like they put love into
it yeah there's something else I have a
Winston in there you might find yeah
it's been different you know away from
Louisiana yeah do you get back home a
lot or what's your vibe like I try to go
back as much as I can but this is
nothing like I can't like I got to drive
to New Orleans you know bad ruse is the
capital so it's like you know it needs
to you know LSU football yeah that's
probably the you know most craziest
thing I feel like you know that's there
yeah yeah I try to go back as much as I
can yeah get that good food
does um were you how did you follow the
UH the last football season pretty
heavily were you invested or are you
might be a Grambling family I'll be a
southern university for Grandma you
might like Jackson State you never I am
a full-blown LSU Tiger yeah Joe Barrow
is my [ __ ] guy that's crazy huh yeah
he's a great guy I love what he did this
year and just what the whole squad did
you know that was unbelievable when you
look back at like when you look back at
plan like in college and stuff was and
you compare it to playing in the pros
like how does it different for
difference for a player like is it did
one does one seem more magical than the
other does one seem more fun well you
know what it's a big difference you know
saying cuz really college was fun and at
the same time magical like what we did
in the NCAA tournament was like magic
yeah but you know I mean II wasn't
supposed to be Duke we wasn't supposed
to be Texas and then we go to the Final
Four you know when you get to the NBA
it's more like business
right you know what I mean you want a
championship is more like you see the
business of the game and you know you
understand kind of now the process is
definitely different from college for
sure for sure do you feel like do you
feel you do you feel because I know a
lot of times like now they talk more
about and they talk more about like
players potentially getting paid and
stuff as college athletes or having
money set aside for them did you did you
ever feel like more used as a player or
did you not think about it or do you
feel more used in the NBA did you have
well in the NBA you know you get paid
right there's money that yeah because
money gets involved within the NBA so
then there's a different there's a
business aspect where in college it's
not really there but there's money being
made but there's money being made and
you know it it made me kind of realize
more than the final four was going on I
walked in Walmart and I seen a number
zero and it says go baby
mmm you know I mean now I'm looking like
for a newborn I felt some type of way
but at the same time like Li Shu is a
nice school and they they give a lot so
I never really had to work on anything
right so yes so that kind of stuff it
didn't affect is so in college I guess
you didn't think about it as much I
didn't think about it at all and when
you get to the pros like money gets
involved oh yeah oh yeah it's crazy host
of 15 checks is crazy and isn't it like
for me I find even just like doing
podcast and like it it starts out fun
and then it starts to become like a
little bit of like a business you know
sometimes so I have to manage like my
brain is like okay am I thinking like
business right now I'm not just trying
to think of you know I'm just having a
good time you know yeah it's well you
know what I've just the best of both
worlds right you get to joke and you
know be funny and have great
conversations on the podcast and get
paid for it
yeah so it's like it's a good blend but
at the same time you know it's a job -
yeah I totally understand yeah it's a
job it's all I think I guess sometimes
it's like my tough thing is like trying
not like sometimes I can't tell if I
should try and put on a mood like a you
know like good or if I should just you
know or if I should
or try to just be myself you know and it
starts to get blurred over a while you
know and you have a podcast that you're
starting up right yes nice tell me about
all that it's called the rabbit in the
beer okay my co-host is here today shout
out why the rabbit the rabbit is here
beautiful young lady in adult industry
and just her aspect of life and athletes
pride you know
a part of life yeah that's what we try
to base it on and kind of get our
viewers to kind of understand just
another take of you know these two
people you know on this side of the
world you know so it's like it's a it's
a great I'm excited about it it's just
gonna be you guys having a good time
yeah we're gonna be talking about a lot
of stuff though yeah you know I'm kind
of humanized you know the the adult
industry yeah and and then also trying
to bring sports you know in the same
package right no kind of that Vegas feel
you know I mean yeah cuz Vegas is really
it's probably against a crossing grounds
I guess I wonder if especially during
that summer league is over they did you
ever playing Summer League or no I did
you did I did and it's it's crazy yeah a
lot of people come out there you think
well Vegas everybody in the world stops
there yeah so it's just like yeah you
know everybody stops there to act up
yeah and so we want to get that we want
you to come in for our come in for 4050
minutes and tell us what's going on with
your life and your experience that
you'll have guests and stuff oh for sure
yeah for sure we got to have you on
there when yeah I would come in and I go
there I'm trying to say I try to stay
out of trouble but I I struggle with I
try to stay off an adult industry I've
been I've seen a lot of y'all's work but
I'm tired of jerking off I'm serious man
it hurts my own feelings after all but
yeah I mean I love y'all working
everything I'm not saying that I respect
the art and everything but oh man yeah
so I guess I mean it'll be interesting
I'll definitely stop by I might have to
wear a blindfold
you know what you know I've got a kind
of immune to it you know just you know
just seeing it it's like oh that's a
that's a fat ass right there yeah and
just keep on going my day well that's a
good attitude to have uh yeah I think
I'll probably I would I'll tend to
visually I'll tend to mill around a fat
ass you know my thing is I just have to
stay off the internet that's what you're
doing yeah it's just too much man I
can't handle just the graphic just the
it's too high definition man I miss that
kind of blurry it yeah you don't know it
was he a strong dude you don't even know
sometime what's up you know if more
mysterious how hard is it like um how
hard was it once you started making
money to kind of fend off like because
with money comes you know the dark arts
come they come and it's easy especially
now with like social media it's easy for
like a you know opportunity to you know
to just slide in your DMS to slide into
your life you know you know what you uh
it's tough this is really really tough
in ways but um I don't know I think it's
how you grow up and you know what you
want for yourself you know what I mean
like did you ever did you struggle did
you ever struggle with like once you got
got like cuz I could have been like I've
started to make some money in my life
I've never made large chunks of money
like you guys I couldn't even imagine
giving that much money to a person at
that time yeah it season it I mean
congratulations it seems intense it is
it is especially if you don't know what
to do with it
yeah you know I mean I it was a point
where you know I had to figure out okay
where do I put this hat or where do I
get this or how do I make sure that I
have money down the road yeah you know
what I mean I had to kind of put that
together yeah you know and I had to lose
some money before I got that done had
like okay I want to go do this oh [ __ ]
damn that was it was there something
crazy you invested in you invest in
something wild in the ostrich farms or
something no no no AUSA's farms I just I
think
crying PJ what's the worst thing you can
do flying private yeah like you just
spend so much I used to fly PJ just to
fly like I'm so [ __ ] cool like yeah I
want to get on a plane 40 grand
oh do that 12 times bike as big big Brad
yeah yeah so you know you gotta figure
your way out you know gotta understand
your money and and what you can do with
it how you can you know make it grow and
put it in situations to you know make
you better financially yeah I could
imagine
yeah this couldn't that's such a wild
thing for a young man to get especially
in that age 19 20 22 years old to get a
large sum of money is risk and do we
from Louisiana man yeah we don't gosh
it's more yeah it's you want to turn
everything into a parade so you know
with speakers on the back while you tell
a stripper just carry a 22 whether you
like a rim out on the stage I seasoned
well I think the when I first saw a
million dollars I was so obsessed with
it I went grab a million I was out of my
account and literally just put it on the
bed just rode around really and I had
some adult what did we just have some
fun like it was like it was the first
million I ever had and I wanted to be
around girls and I wanted to just have
like a big orgy or something like some
movie type [ __ ] you know so I got some
real good stories that's how grown of
iris got started
[Laughter]
does that kind of is it hard to like
kind of curtail that kind of behavior
cuz I like I get it like I get addicted
I know for myself like I get addicted to
like if I start watching pornography I'd
get into watching it you know or that or
sexual stuff you know is it hard to like
is it hard to kind of is it hard to not
let that it did that kind of stuff ever
affect your your basketball life or did
it ever yeah there was a point in time
when you know I would say have to be
when I was with the Clippers I had just
moved to LA and it was like my first
time like being in LA with a lot so I
was just like every night I was just
like if we didn't have practice the next
day I was definitely in somebody's red
carpet party or I'm somewhere crazy
girls strip club or something just
living it up just having a good time so
yeah you know you kind of you kind of
got to go through it in order to say you
know what I don't wanna do this right I
mean that's my advice to another athlete
like you know you got to see it first
you got experience nobody feels like and
then you're like okay I'm all about the
greater good so let me kind of shorten
this up and let me figure out the right
thing yeah growing up it just some of us
growing up I guess how you think yeah
you gotta grow up especially for we're
from we never seen I know like I ain't
never seen nothing so it's like oh yeah
Baton Rouge they didn't even have they
had some [ __ ] all everything looked like
they had done it maybe in that made it
in the 70s man what like I'll be so
shocked when I go downtown Baton Rouge
now cuz there's so much I'm like yeah
that's a nice hotels the stuff now yeah
did you um yeah I could I just try to
think about what that's like like man if
I got if I was if I was good at
something like a sport I would not even
want to be playing at the game a lot of
time I feel like this game is weird
let's get done with the game so I can go
have fun you know well you gotta get
that check you know that's right you
gotta get to you know sometimes a game
you can make $12,000 for one game so
it's like you gotta be there you gotta
be there so that
the easy part going to the game yeah did
you ever did you ever play with any
players that smoke cigarettes that still
played well I know only persons would be
close to smoking a cigarette it's
probably probably or seeds you know he
likes to drink so oh yeah he likes a
little cigar
it looks like you I could see that maybe
he where'd that headband in the club or
not
no you know he is definitely worst dress
ever
Celtics so you know he probably would
wear a [ __ ] headband in two like does
he have a pretty good sense of humor
sorta yeah it's not bad yeah yeah he's
Cali boy so you know they're kind of
like yeah yeah yeah yeah and what about
Blake Griffin though he's really funny
his like he has a like a comedian like
feel every time you say something yeah I
know so he's kind of funny but yeah
that's the only other one BMB a guy that
I know his Blake Griffin yeah that's the
same thing I find about him someone that
can I'm surprised and times when he's
funny cuz I don't at the first thing
he's gonna be and then I might oh he's
joking yeah he kind of gets what's going
on yeah he has a humor yeah he was
always like a comedic like relief doing
hard times we Clippers we got this
question that came in right here from a
gentleman right here just a little white
guy oh my god which other NBA player did
you fight with the most or who do you
dislike the most and all he could
rephrase it was there a guy in whenever
you played in the NBA that you had like
gay arch-nemesis yes
I couldn't stand Kris Humphries Kris
Humphries he won't say he wouldn't know
he was Kim Kardashian's boyfriend oh
yeah the big he look like bottom man I
think he just was like yeah
I'd like to show you gotta yeah big baby
how do you like that like and I'm just
like brother like why you gotta be so
money properly like like god damn like
it made me sick like [ __ ] like
everytime haha yeah you almost had that
stress like that sounds like that count
from Sesame Street yeah yeah big baby
yeah yeah like you know I just I
couldn't stand him I just really
couldn't like at all
yeah well he's Kim Kardashian's yeah
yeah she definitely she really went
through it like some no he does have a
he yeah he seems a little bit more like
a model man
yeah like preppy kid he went to the prep
school when he's - JA oh yeah
all the girls love Oh what about that
yeah oh yeah you like that oh check my
stocks yes definitely definitely
definitely that's interesting when you
were when when I went to school in Baton
Rouge they had this was him when Master
P and then were really had really set
off and you were probably still at the
university honey I was at you high at
the time and uh that's when Master P in
his it was really they had really set it
off then when they had Silkk the Shocker
C murder and they used to come to the
rec center you know and they had guys
know joke that would stand on the side
of the court holding their clothes they
were gonna wear after the game yeah and
they would bring guys they brought a guy
that played for the Celtics I think
named Anthony something this was before
your time there but they would fly guys
in and they would have games with like
all-stars you know every day at the Rec
Center yeah I was a young kid yeah and
me and Garret used to always go up there
and try to play a pickup game and it
would be masterpiece if the shot see
murder you might have mystical on the
side you got
X on the side I was like what I'm like
looking like this the whole [ __ ] No
Limit in here yeah like you know it used
to be some like epic runs you know
Strohmeyer Swift would be in here
College temple all type of Jabari like
it was more it was so fun to watch it
boy it was great yeah dang yeah that's a
that was like my first experience
watching basketball when I got over to
Baton Rouge it was at the rec game see
in those games and then I would go watch
um you know trying to take who played
yet that was when Strohm I played when I
was in college who else played then this
was before sprite yeah Taurus right
through the nicest kids who's yeah some
big hands like like like watt Leonard's
oh my god I'm talking about some you
know we used to skip school and used to
go over to the WCA
and he was just like I'll be sleeping he
just slap his hand across wake up go to
class who's the UH yeah I remember when
I was growing up he was a salmon and our
Chris Duhon was that sound too hard and
Taurus was that slot L yeah and they
would play each other and they had to
shut it they had to shut the berries
down epic matchups epic those dudes had
to play yeah Chris Duhon was great um
would you think of watching do you still
watch LSU hoops yeah
what about trunk Tremonti did you look
he was one of my waters one of my
favorite point guards I've ever seen
play yeah he was so little
yeah I didn't I didn't realize how
little he was just been seen and play
he's like so fast so fast you know I'm
so good I felt like I feel like he
because he all I think he's run some
with this ultra fury plays in their
d-league main yeah in Maine
yep you know he's just a guy that I feel
like if would have went more in the
tournament went down a lot probably been
the first round because he's so good
he's clutch shots I was looking at the
the Maryland n-c-double-a game yeah made
the winning shot yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I was just like that was so you
know the way he maneuvers and getting in
lane so so craft has angles that are
just different
while he's moving you know I love
watching him man I was so bummed that uh
that I don't can't remember he left
earlier he just he might have been a
senior he left kind of early I think he
was a junior who loved watching him yeah
yeah he was so good man but yeah I
follow him I try and keep tabs with
what's going on with him mmm
but yeah I'm a huge LSU basketball fans
still when you I had a question about
when you when you guys were before when
I went to school there they used to have
this coach named Tyndall was his last
name and this is I think under coach
Brown who did you guys have we have John
Brady
oh this was under coach Brady so he had
an assistant coach and I used to write
play papers for some of the players like
they had a Brian Bashar a couple of
Ronald d'Ivry I don't know if I don't do
for you or not I love about Toronto he
was or rolling rolling
I used to write his papers and the the
assistant coach would meet me in the
museum on campus and give me tickets to
the games and give me autographs you
know Lamont look like straight convicts
yeah
open-face go I remember the month now
walk bowlegged man he looked like a
straight convict come straight to
college like he was out of the hands
first man no question that's crazy
that's hilarious
who was the who's the most ganglia
looking dude if you out there on the
court when you see this do you like how
am I gonna play this guy because his
body doesn't make any sense you know
who's just Gumby doubt they're just link
to a level you just I don't I would have
to say about anybody just would they
have one Lorne that was just too long or
something just somebody you know I just
felt like LeBron was just too big just
so big so fast so smart you know to me
as much as like a cheat code yeah
like playing with the Celtics and
playing Cleveland when they were Connor
on the UPS and you know fighting for
that you know Eastern Conference
championship like he was amazing
like you know to me and then it's like
five other guys like I understand why he
went to Miami right like you know I mean
like who does that you you you're
winning in Cleveland you're getting
there but it's just not enough because
the Celtics are [ __ ] busting your ass
you go to Miami you know what I mean so
it's just like so it made sense to you
when he went down there made sense
because we were [ __ ] tagging his ass
yeah like he would leave the court like
sick really like salty a.m. we had a
team you know what I mean and then we
understood what we had to do to beat him
and so he went and got more help and he
did is it once you get into because
right when you got into the pros you had
you guys won the championship first year
yeah rip up your straight to the chip it
was it was a crazy you think it had
anything to do with you or not
a little bit yeah not in a bad way but
in my head I'd be like out of [ __ ] yeah
cuz the rookie we'd do all the rookie
duties you know what I mean we you know
we make sure they got the peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches we make sure that
you know what I'm saying that biggest
around we make sure that everything is
cool they calls at 4:00 in the morning
you know and practice suit you know
practice was my days like you know it
would help a lot yeah and then I would
play a little bit too I played a little
bit so was it uh was it nerve what did
you get nervous when you first started
playing in the NBA is there a nervous
thing and it or is it still just a
basketball game it's that's a basketball
game but I think when you get to the NBA
it's a whole different level and you can
kind of see it you know that mean
because I I'll never forget we were
playing a exhibition game mm-hmm and we
were playing the Raptors and they had on
John they had brought a kit kat bar
yarny number one big you know on nany
yeah yeah yeah I'm an idiot Lee and we
go over there and it's our first game
and I see my Jersey
you know from bedrooms yeah [ __ ]
started crying like a baby oh my god oh
my god Katie
look at me like alright we can't put him
into the third quarter I was like
goddamn like it was just uh it was just
you know we never seen nothing like this
before like ya know so I [ __ ] cried
like a baby
it's the surrealist of it all yeah man I
made it now you know what we promised I
grew up in the Eaton Park area
Gus young mm-hmm it's some kind of
Midtown mm-hmm so it's kind of like the
last of the number streets so if like
the first Street all the way to you know
so from 35th to 49th is my neighborhood
mm-hmm so tough yeah real weak mostly
black white we have a couple sprinkles
of whites and Mexicans in there you know
but yeah it was so warm though we had
this new grown-up and when I was growing
up called Brian Purvis right mm-hmm and
he was the first white dude ever to hang
out like he was the first wig I ever you
know yeah I remember the term Widger
remember bro he was they've never seen
it at school before so the teachers
didn't know what to do they'd never seen
it you know they put him in a learning
disabled class just because he wore a
red skin starter hood he pulled over and
[ __ ] smoked more bras at all and
smoked Newports that's the only reason
so they're like we keep this guy yeah
he's crazy
my grandmother smoked Newports but he
would always be he would be so we'd have
to eat lunch with the special ed
children so he would always be posting
them he would just be dribbling an
invisible basketball just posting them
up and a lot of [ __ ] like you had dude
they can't even singing he's [ __ ]
just post invisible posting a mom man
that's crazy it was fun that wasn't it
it was but it like I remember just when
we used to eat it was like a [ __ ]
party yeah oh grandma cooking like oh
[ __ ] we got everybody the neighborhood
about to come down I see by the sale
plates like it's cracking like this the
way we use food there it's a form of
entertainment and I don't think nobody
else really does
that like you know a crawfish ball yeah
reason to get to yet this it's something
about it create there you have food that
creates environment for people to have
fun yeah yeah there's just something
about it yes standing around crawfish
eating it because you still talk and
your face is burning a little Larry your
granddaddy got that [ __ ] big yellow
[ __ ] on his cheek you don't know what's
going on dancing doing some type of
zydeco or yeah people while you were
playing [ __ ] that even instrument I just
miss being young I think a lot of times
know that you were a [ __ ] hand for
[ __ ] wild inches
I used to some awesome I'm a war like a
lot of shirts bro I remember that I did
because I was real small so I put on
five or six or seven but then the
problem was I remember my pay my legs
was so little din because my body would
get all big because of the shirt o
entirely listening to now Libre was all
right dude Nelly was one of the Nelly
brought black and white people made
everybody feel like they could dance I
feel like Oh for white people it was of
one time I feel like dude I really felt
like first CD I ever bought before CD
with Mellie Grammer
whoa God it was good I would say tips
real first video I masturbated Oh have
you ever seen - now we're talking about
your podcast
tip drill was like a porno I saw that I
mean a drill I need if you see a tip
drill point on my really um please pull
that video up if you can we got here
necklace damn this came on BT uncut you
remember that some like you've got the
wildest nicknames but you can't have
bone marrow but just my boy liver
transplant
it's the blue and I always this it oh
damn oh look at that
Oh see that that's porn back in our day
that's like yeah yeah wow yeah yeah
Nellie mmm lunatic that man took his
mask off like watching that video young
that was that was like definitely like
I've never seen this one you've never
seen this no oh my goodness this is like
right before like yes they did really it
was a serious video yeah this is really
heavy man thing I do need to call my
sponsor these [ __ ] is athletic out
there talk about real tracks that leads
the guy you got it started for sure for
sure um a lot of rap a lot of rappers
come through NBA - so the lot of those
guys invites all out to party or just
kind of their own things and I've man I
got so many rapper friends it's crazy
yeah yeah who parties well really
oh my god yeah I walked in here he's
like yeah you know I think that you know
when you turn the lights off you just
you know you're being sneaky yeah
otter sneak asleep going on like yeah
you come over here come and meet me in
this room yeah game a clue yeah like God
am I crazy was definitely he's
definitely that guy yeah I could see
that man always up and I knew you and I
messaged about this I've always been a
huge booty fan and he's one of like the
guys you know I'd love to be able to
talk with him one day
do you have you ever had any experience
as a [ __ ] that's my guy really
[ __ ] is my guys see some hardest worker
bras yeah he is bro and he I've been out
to his house in Atlanta big [ __ ]
mansion [ __ ] go car it's [ __ ]
volleyball football core you know
football will feel like he's a sports
fan and he's just he's a legend in his
in his world you know I mean it's just
gangster music and just having that
image he's the last one really almost
really he what he is for sure for sure
in did you notice though he was he was
incarcerated whenever they had when he
whenever social media came out so he
didn't wouldn't even on it for like
eight years so then I've cut someone's
up like his social media is so raw
sometimes whoo raw yeah yeah $25 I was
like whoa he's fearless he's really you
know I I was like bro you need a reality
show yeah
he was like yeah you sure you know I was
like yeah man like you're hilarious
and just the concept of him loving his
kids I don't see that like yeah he
really loves his kids in that and I said
you need to show the world a different
light you've been through a crazy path
yeah and now it's time to show people
who you truly are and why people love
you so much you know this man has a busi
batch every year oh yeah giving away
free haircuts give it away clothes he
knew at the part we need 72 barbers out
he does not he's fearless
you need this now let's do it I love you
yeah I think it'd be the mayor man I
think he could I think he could he gotta
clean up some things he did just come
out with dangerous perfume put this on
your lady Jackson Tennessee is going now
it does get it to his bromo well when
does he Saudis that but it really though
he's the he is the hardest-working
person that I follow on social media
like it never in Ian's men and he's
trying to always figure out something
yeah you know the man got busi chips
yeah Boosie juice everything boosting
dude my friend is a isn't a boo see neck
brace dude yeah boost is the neck
bracing you press it on the side and
it's like yeah and the neck brace will
even it's got a little thing a motor in
it
if you [ __ ] up a little dance for you
and his mother's a teacher yes
mother's a teacher yes still a teacher
I'm and still the teacher is still you
know in the neighborhood people love
yeah my brother has I think maybe done
some yard work or something for them but
uh but yeah he always says the nicest
things about her yeah it's Connie
it's crazy man he's a such a legend
though he is you know
a real gangster buddy really but he's a
real gangster that's the thing that
people don't realize about [ __ ] like
[ __ ] got like 30 to 40 month bugs
around him all the time and he touch
[ __ ] something's gonna happen to you
and that's how he rolls you know to me
so like and you know that's amazing yeah
like they love him you know from his
neighborhood he's done so much good
things and you know steady doing good
things and so they'll ever love him man
yeah they do
he's one of the last people I see on
social media that is really a hundred
percent real no matter if he's wrong or
not to others whatever's is his point of
view that's what it is you know like he
um what do you say a couple like a year
ago he said some stuff on he's like man
half this television making these
children gay many I'll put in all this
you know television you it's only that's
kind of crazy but it's just it's exactly
who he is
yeah it is you know you know yeah this
offends his comments on doing yeah you
came out yeah I remember him telling me
you can't put don't know yeah well years
oh man he don't know where his next meal
coming from my I love you booty I'm just
joking man no I mean literally man he's
my favorite person to follow
he's just unprecedented style for sure
for sure um when you look at like so you
look at your future like what do you
kind of see for yourself you know
obviously you guys are starting to
podcast you're such a big personality
you know I feel like people so many
people love you
what do you kind of see uh in your
future you know I definitely see myself
in front of the TV yeah you know what I
mean or in a production phase because I
love entertainment so much and I really
feel like I can be on TV and be a host
somewhere but my dish shameless yeah we
had a question right here about it this
gentleman came up not this look at the
Scout that called Malone hitter on you
see you tomorrow
what up the oh what a big baby this is
Ian in Salt Lake I
just wondering I know davis you were in
shameless a while back and kg just got
into acting with uncut gems but do you
see yourself ever getting back into
acting getting game would you think man
hell yeah yeah i think that's a you know
i think that's definitely area i can
kind of conquer you know I've always
seen myself the opposite version of the
rock like you got the rock and you gotta
get the role yeah so I've always seen
yourself yes I've always seen myself
acting and you know that shameless
interview like they called me up like
hey you know come in this is my first
interview like my first I just put my
actor access out just got me a firm to
kind of you know start giving me
auditions and they're like oh we got
this shameless roll and I'm like ok it's
kind of though he's like yeah you're
gonna be in jail you're gonna be
bodyguarding in and but it was like but
you're gay and I was like oh it's my
first role I'm gay alright I was
rehearsing the role like I wasn't
getting and then my my my coach is like
I think you're gay and so I'll never
forget it like I literally put my shirt
before I went from auditioned it was
like you put my shirt and I turned
around I was like hey and they were like
oh you got the part you know you got the
part and I was just like damn and so it
was like wow you got you got a flavor
you understand like man that's your
first one and so after that I just been
getting all different types of like
request auditions and I'm feeling like I
got it like a space like okay cool this
is what I can do you know what I want to
do do you feel like you I mean obviously
you were you just a big man there's
nothing you could do about that I mean
some of that's nature you know you might
have had some you know you might have
stepped in some magical water something
who knows what happened if you did
something but also it could just a lot
of its nature yeah do you feel do you
always feel like like sports was like
you're like I have a friend who I was
just with last week and he won the he
won a MVP in the world
series right he played for like 12 years
and I was talking to him and he said you
know I was I was good at baseball but I
never really I never knew how much of a
Pat was a passion it was for me what was
your relationship like that with with
hoops was that definitely like your
passion and now it's kind of like oh it
was my passion but I didn't know how
good I was
yeah you know I thought it was good like
okay yeah you're good at neighborhood
you know middle school with and I
started playing a you and I think it was
going into my junior year and I'm like
it was the ABCD all-star camp and I went
out there it was the Austin I made the
all-star game I was like damn well you
know I'm looking at all these guys like
Oh Dwight Howard and Josh sniff and jr.
sniffing Sebastian tell these are all
guys that are predicted to go out of
high school Wow and so I'm like ranked
13 in nation and stuff and I'm like I
never thought you know me cuz I thought
I was gonna be run out of tiger stayed
in like football yeah
and so wow me you know being there and
seeing all that it made me like hey
let's go get this money and now my focus
like okay I got a chance to make some
money you know where we from we got a
chance make some money to get an extra
money yeah we gonna make it you know I
mean no matter what so especially you
don't have anybody like really yeah a
lot of people get opportunities through
their family and stuff like that like
that's one thing I never had really that
much you know like your dad gives you an
opportunity you know or something like
that you know but did you love it do you
love playing basketball I do I do I love
it yeah you know I do you love it I
didn't have to wear a [ __ ] hell man
yeah like I could wear my hey you know
my hey claim Here I am like football
guys I'm left half okay you know score a
touchdown
you got to be yourself your personality
got to be there yeah so you know I want
to do this if I couldn't score
touchdowns I didn't want to play on the
[ __ ] you
oh yeah then we're gonna put you there -
I want to be the guy yeah you gotta me
like but then I realized I left tackles
get paid damn near morning when you look
at this season with the with the virus
and the way a lot of the guys like can't
can't they couldn't keep the season
moving we got a question right here from
this gentleman right here and he's
obviously incarcerated I decided to see
my boy Mario McCoy in the skateboarding
Olympics for the first time just what
are your thoughts on the world
overreacting Gang Gang yeah hey bro get
out safely man what I want to say is yet
on top of his question like with it with
the guys now they just cancelled the
season yeah so would that have been
crazy like if that was your senior year
that of the year you were coming would
you have out of freaking like went crazy
Wow cuz you think about it this is what
I this is what I want to do with my life
and now I have to be my last year I need
to find some a job right now I was like
I can't go do what I was you know doing
in school and you know going to play for
like after I leave like yeah
it's discouraging but you know hopefully
you know this thing will die down and
guys can get back to their regular of
normal cells and kids can fulfill their
dreams of walking across the NBA stage
and shake it out and Silver's and an you
know so hopefully you know I just know
it's tough but we understand what's
going on here
right and you know and that's bigger
than any sports it's just the people
well being and being healthy and stuff
like that so did you think it was real
at first like how real did you think the
virus was I didn't think it was real it
hurt III because when I was look I watch
the news and I was like China like these
are wild they're let's be honest their
Chinese are why old yeah I was rosy over
there I'm not even joking I'm on a train
bus some dudes eating [ __ ] Falcon
feet on the train next to me not even
joking out of a bag man just having a
couple Falcon feet man yes yeah one of
them I think crawled off the [ __ ]
back
they don't like listen but I'm serious
I'm not joking about that like I'm just
sitting on a train and a man had a
little bag of Falcon feet and he's just
happy evening a couple hot nuggets yeah
and he's polishing them all it smells
horrible nope but nobody else even
noticed it's just just eatin hopefully
they eat wild stuff no wilder than
Louisiana like things we wouldn't even
eat there the like nah that's that's
great I seen having a Doberman [ __ ]
leg you know over there yeah it's super
crazy I thought I loved food until I
seen this I think uh yeah I'll take the
spicy garlic bats rosemary redheads what
well you know everybody got their own
way and hopefully you know this
situation they can stopped it yeah I
push it with the virus how much of a
scare so I know your co-hosts here works
in has worked in adult industry how much
of the word like is the dole energy
still poppin or people use in like you
know what's going on with that well it's
it's it's not really poppin as much you
know that me my you know my call she
tells me all the time that a lot of
people are affected you know in the dog
industry from this situation yeah you
think about all the young ladies that
have jobs all the young ladies to have
you know I would say you know give me a
word tricks or escorting export like
here is a sex worker we've had yeah yes
so it's my old job it's a job for a lot
of here so they don't get to touch bases
with those people because of the virus
and um you know I've been uh I've been
noticing that the girls been attached to
only fans page oh yes Riley's only fans
page is its booming the booming once
guys go take a look at that Mico home
page you know and then you know and she
let me know about the other things that
girls can do in that industry to make
money yeah because of this virus so it's
hard on everybody right now especially
the hoes yeah yeah these these a lot of
these hoes are really struggling I get
you know these loserman hoes I'm not
talking about these illegitimate hoes
man I'm not I refused to talk about them
talking about these real hugs man you
know these down since day one bottom
bottom bottom this is yeah foundation
yeah these real real legit ones Nick we
got another question that came in it's a
nice word you chose that's not troubled
fell off a bit there's a tiger Joe
exotic you watching oh my god we'll get
right into that here's your boy right
here another incarcerated fight big baby
Davis checking in from Massachusetts
okay what was it like to influence a
culture and a generation of young sports
fans and a city like Boston yeah what is
up with that man cuz Boston it's
something else bro yeah you know they're
really wild man it's the white Chinese I
think they really active Wow I will call
Boston like especially south these like
black people they are like they don't
play no games like is no joke what I'm
so it was just magical cuz it cuz you go
you know you get drafted in oh yeah you
go straight to the Celtics who the most
winningest team in the NBA history you
got all these banners and all Bill
Russell and all this so it was like damn
like wow I really up I'm a part of
something like crazy and just to have my
own niche you know what I mean like I
just to have my own niche meaning that
the fact that being big baby in a Celtic
Jersey it was great it's like oh yeah
this day people like oh my god oh my god
I feel like about a plate for the damn
Timberwolves or something like it when
they carry they won't care so it's just
like I didn't know how big you know the
Celtic organization was when I really
got there you know what I mean yeah I
was like to be a part of something like
that and be a part of culture in that
way and you know have your own place in
there and have a championship it just
means a lot and you know I can always go
back to Boston like it's you know it's
just it's a great feeling because the
fans they really love sports like even
the girls like I got your picture about
big babies autographed balls so yeah
like they they love they love their
sports you know I do
I love these sports it really is true
huh it is like looking back on all your
NBA time do you feel like you made the
most of it as a athlete and a competitor
no because you know you want to win more
than one championship we want to make as
much money as possible you know I had
the best time while I was there and you
know my time got cut short cause injury
and that's just saying I had a wonderful
time I love it like I I have my place
like you know what I mean no matter
where I go somebody's like hey that's a
big baby right there
oh you only guess I've been most
seriously no joke I mean yeah here we
got a question right here from this
guy's been hunting oh look at him you
know a big baby big fan you guys both my
name is Noah from Santa Rosa California
hey quick question for big baby are you
a fan of the new style where the young
players are wearing the short shorts or
do you like the more traditional kind of
baggy or look like when you played let
me know I'm uh I'm really I'm I don't
care like you don't I mean I don't want
them too short right yeah you know I'm
like you know I mean I don't want them
too too short yeah
legs because yeah would you yeah would
you feel comfortable letting people see
all that at work okay now that's a
lengthy short right so yeah well you now
you cut off half that short how you you
on the field that we usually don't be
able to shoot yeah
you know what I when you pull them down
a little bit before you try to sag them
a little bit you know what I mean cuz my
thighs rub together oh I don't I don't
want to start a fire and we just have to
put something on your legs so they
wouldn't uh get to Vaseline him or
anything like that or no the tight so I
would have them come down yeah that's
right and they're smooth and you know I
wouldn't you know like I said start a
fire
yeah you gotta keep it classy out there
um so living in Vegas right that sounds
intense bro you stayed big is all [ __ ]
everyday the [ __ ] party for you I'm
like no not really I'm staying summer
instead you know my next-door neighbor
is like 70 yeah I don't have no young
kids around me like unless you go on the
strip right unless you go look and have
a good time Yeah right you know other
than that I would you know you know I
feel like I meet prostitutes everywhere
yeah cuz I think cuz there's a lot of
them this living here so I forgot mean
processes all the time or pimp really
now have you ever had it's from run-ins
with some crazy pimps yeah I've had some
wild stories with the pimp I think one
of them one of my best friends had gotta
chill he's in jail in jail for 10 years
and he's like bro when I get out I'm
coming to Cali we're having a good time
you know whatever and so we go we go to
this two-week he gets here and I'm like
yo what you want to do that you do not
gotta get laid
yeah he's like that's the first thing
I'm trying to do yeah then yeah so we go
to the strip club but kind of like fish
a little you know little shrimp net out
there you know make it rain see if we
can grab ya this is dime the oh my god
something at quarters to some chick
yeah laundry baby
we literally roll over here we do all
that laundry coin okay and come back to
the house so we're driving right and so
she's in the car you know they're in the
back making out you know he's getting
busy you know we see this car following
us and we're like he's following us so
you know now I'm like yes so she's
acting weird and nice you know you know
we get to the house and we see the same
car like how the [ __ ] does she know
we're here yeah and it's her pimp know
she was like you
he was like you left the strip club you
was possibly the strip club what the
[ __ ] are you doing like going [ __ ]
crazy
what'd he look like did he look like a
pimp that he had long hair definitely
had to [ __ ] braids you would thought
you'd have thought he was on that whoop
that trick I played on the movie why and
so you know he kid sounds like that's my
whole that's my pitch I'm like what and
what are y'all saying would like hey we
was just trying to have fun we met just
got explained there and so he's like we
settled things you know we had to pay
him some money and she had to go back to
the strip club
she was mad at her pimp though scared
for a second for a second but then I
kind of like bad moods mo crazy like all
right like you know I mean go that's not
a whispers or something yeah well one of
the clubs you know they always have
those clothes where people would get
like sometimes shot outside of view it's
like Oh secrets over come over to
secrets in Avondale
it's always like something like whispers
you know oh yeah you got to come over to
uh yeah you barely heard this always
something yeah we got in trouble for
stealing her from the strip clubs yeah I
got in trouble for that man
so will you guys have any pants on you
on you guys podcast and what will it be
like you think a pimp would be really
interesting because that's such a I mean
it's really of I feel like it's kind of
a frowned upon job but I feel like you
know everybody needs like kind of a
manager you know or a for you know
everybody's got to work for a foreman
you know yeah you know least have a guy
worked for we didn't like we used to do
uh you know cleaning out wishing wells
and [ __ ] in our town because I had a lot
of wishing wells in Covington yeah so we
were coined up so I'd be down there
getting you know sending [ __ ] up the
road all kind of thing man mostly as
people think its wishes a lot of it they
think it's not that much money you got a
lot of people throwing furniture down
there so word I find a sword wants a
sword
yeah bloody store well it was a regular
store but had blood on it yeah that's
the murder weapon you'll be down there
[ __ ] two days he's come up with nine
dollars you know that's a real that's a
cool hustle and then you got a hand you
know you got to give 60% of it to the
captain you know breaking him on two
dollars and the bees to that are down
there people don't think about these
people most people wish apparently they
wish for bees oh because there's so many
[ __ ] bees and those things man oh
yeah I would because water mud they're
the heat people throw everything a lot
of people use it for recycling is [ __ ]
people think this recycle you know I'm
gonna put this [ __ ] in there man
nobody's coming to get that wishing well
what else we got in it hey baby what's
going on my name's Tommy G from Lockport
Illinois just got a question for you big
baby
if you'd want to talk about it can you
talk about the n-c-double-a do you guys
really have to go to class the athletes
big names maybe getting paid off people
getting cars who knows let me know
thanks yeah how'd it go down there
because I was getting but I was getting
I was getting paid to write papers for
players so I'm sure you guys did you
have it easy to get to go to class I
went to class right because there's
rules like right you got to go to class
to play like right now but I skipped a
lot of class yeah because I know what I
wanted to do right I wanted to go to the
NBA yeah you know the only class you
really need is to be at practice yeah
and then like you know the class to pass
you know get your grades like you know
what I mean like you got to get your
grades and stuff like that but like I
was so focused on going to the NBA like
I didn't really worry about what I you
know I just felt like okay I need to get
some business classes some account
managing classes but this kinesiology
over here I learned about yes somebody
else's yeah I got my plan on doing that
so I changed my major to theater and
then in you know really yeah she took
some theater class yeah so uh
improvident stuff all that stuff and
just learning the stage and just the
history and stuff like that but then you
know basketball took over yeah and told
me hey you can go to the draft now
you're gonna get paid I was out so you
ever wish you would stay longer no I
it's risky I I wish I could've right you
know but John Brady didn't [ __ ] want
me so it was like oh the next guy coming
in hey get your ass out of here so I was
like but you know we we got taken care
of yeah we got taken care of like LSU is
not like a school where you know you
walk around and you're broke
right they go make sure like hey you got
food to eat you got money in your pocket
you alright come on
so they really took care of us
especially the Boosters out there they
really show love yeah and I guess they
had it's probably I mean you have to you
there has to be some it's deservedly so
did you feel like you were taking care
of extra or do you just feel like no
this kind of makes sense it kind of
makes sense but at the same time I was
kind of like locked because you gotta
think about it like I'm from Baton Rouge
college temples or you know first
african-american you know he was kind of
my mentor right because his father you
said was he the first player that you
ever play for LSU yeah and so when some
one of his sons played with you he's an
NBA right now that's right that's right
yeah so um you know I I didn't have to
take a visit like Roy Williams was like
I'm [ __ ] coming down there and
they're not letting you go and I with
the high school on campus so y-yeah if
you go anywhere we're gonna kill you
Yeah right across the street yeah
literally right across senior high
school was all i mean it it's almost
surrounded by campus most definitely
soon as you come on campus you are yeah
it was oh my god it was so hard really
the laboratory school so it was like
does that mean I mean I don't know no
it's like hard right so I mean I'm in my
senior year algebra two with eighth
graders so imagine being this star
basketball player you got a little
Johnny oh oh my god cuz see you at the
game help you with you my beaker was
like kids so smart and I just I made it
that's all I mean it yeah so that's wild
yeah
is it hard um how much is party and like
affected your life over the years
because partying for me was kind of
tough like I would get you know I like I
got into drugs and alcohol for a while
for who were me and I started to get a
little bit out of hand so I had to I had
to like shut it down you know have you
ever have you had tough times I mean it
doesn't cool there's cool stories out
there about you with weed and cool stuff
oh yeah yeah I have some I have some
crazy stories I'm a weed smoker yeah
smoking weeds it's like eighth grade
yeah you know now it's kind of now I
think there's new laws where it's okay
right they can't
yeah there's certain laws whereas okay I
think they can't test the players
anymore I'm not sure Nick can you check
that out well it's I think it's more
like doing the virus series that guys
won't get tested so they don't have
to worry about things yeah you're
definitely gonna get tested you know
could some players play hi you think in
the NBA oh no question
really Matt Barnes played hi every
[ __ ] game Wow
he and Steven Jackson have a podcast oh
yeah yeah Matt Barnes play like I'll be
scared to hang out man sometimes like
Matt you burn wine and a I'm gonna take
a shower I'm like god damn like hi every
it but it didn't affect his way like he
would be out there competing and it's
like a white he's mixed he's mixed see
he I think of a hundred percent white
guy couldn't do that I don't at all yeah
yeah always yeah I think I think us I
think this is a generalization but I
think black guys and white guys get
affected by weed differently like I
would see black guys are gonna smoke
weed and do some amazing I could see
what guys it's a weed and not do
anything at all like be paralyzed mm-hmm
I knew it I'd have friends I could smoke
and play a whole game it just blew my
mom yeah I think the last white guy to
smoke weed during the game was Larry
Bird yeah or Jason Wynn's member that
guy Sam Perkins Marah he looked for him
to play for the Sonics Wow he used to
get high yeah Russia Wallace for sure he
might have been shooting weed into his
arm no question he might have his
suppositories brother put two in his but
I can see some of these guys being out
there hi oh that's Matt Barnes right
there
no that's Damon Stoudamire him and
Rasheed they were always getting in
trouble for we young yeah that's
remarkable man and that's why I think it
was just yeah like I had us don't see
how some guys can do that but that's the
difference between me and a lot of
different yeah I couldn't do it really I
could not do it did you ever get high
and play one game Sacramento and I had a
good game you did but it was just like I
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
everything it was like I was just
staring like one time I was at the
free-throw line it was like they gave me
the ball and I just was staring at the
rim yeah like literally staring at oh no
shoot hurry up
you got two seconds to shoot it I was
literally standing there for like a
whole like nine second stone that's
crazy were you scared no you know that's
cool like doc yeah okay okay
did uh did Austin to play with it did
his son play with you guys yeah he did
mmm did they did his son get a special
treat because I remember son played with
the pelicans how could you know okay it
was it was tough you know what I mean
because as an athlete you know what I
mean you watch I mean as athlete and you
come in this game and there's really no
handouts or no something given to you
right now I'm siddhis when you get there
yeah you got to make you're gonna earn
your keep and getting make sure you get
your you know on the totem pole you know
I mean so it's like it was hard for
awesome because his dad was the GM
president and you know he just had a
hard year in New Orleans and yeah
everybody's like oh he's not panning out
you know what I mean right and then now
you have your father so hey come over
here son let me show the world that you
can play let me give you all this money
and show the world but at the same time
you can't play right he just had to find
his niche and find who he was and I
think he had to humble himself hmm he
had to really humbled herself because
you know
dukey's they just think they're oh yeah
yeah so he had to kind of figure that
out I think after that he's become a
good solid point yeah you know his and
in if my son was about to get kicked out
the lead and I'm the [ __ ] president
okay son come here come here give me 10%
20% of that contract I just gave you god
damn it oh we're gonna have you over
here yeah we're gonna have you over here
and then he found his niche yeah you
know now he's sticking and he's you know
he's an elite for sure
my last question Apple you know Zion
Williams sign once has a big body tight
yeah he's got that body type when you
see him do you relate to that body
type at all do you kind of sorta I
didn't jump as high um but the game is
so fast now right and you see the injury
that he just had yeah yeah I'm gonna
score even started yet or even started
so I think he has to understand how to
play the game so he can play for a
longer time
I think the way his game is if he
doesn't find another way it's balls to
the wall he plays yes if he doesn't find
another way to be successful then he's
not gonna play a long time Wow
because he's so explosive and that
leaves you right you know what I mean oh
yeah totally
right Blake Griffin used to jump out the
frickin gym yeah you know now he jumps
as high as he needs to yes and now it
did but at the same time he opened up
the three-point range
right like Griffin wasn't a good
three-point shooting when he came in
lead now he's capable of knocking down
shooting 35 36 40 percent from the
three-point line yeah so he has to Zion
has to figure out his niche how can he
be successful and kind of uses energy in
spurts because the game is so freakin
fast and every time he's using the the
the the you know Nemean is pounding
pounding pounding pounding pounding so
like I think you know him
developing kind of like a back to the
basket a slow down type of field I aim I
think he'll play longer do you um do you
think you played the the the the best
way that you could have played or he
lived well yeah I think I think I'm the
last of the fat boys right in the Oliver
Miller Oh him the Robert
tractor-trailers I think I'm the last of
those guys my if right cuz draymond
Green was kind of one of those guys
after me but yeah he was little strong
he was not strong or sorry but he was he
wasn't that fat though yeah but he was
kind of like chubby fat you know I mean
then he kind of took his game to another
level when he yeah became more little
more yeah yeah you know he barely could
shoot but you know but he's such a
facilitator defensively minded type of
guy and might yeah yeah yeah so like
he's kind of those guys that made the
transition into like okay the game is up
and down more I'm a big heavyset guy I
got a slim down so Zion gonna have
figure out his way and he'll be all
right is there was was ever like a lot
of racist stuff in the league or people
are pretty chill in the NBA um depends
you you run into [ __ ] right guys
that are you know that kind of don't see
both side of the world right you don't I
mean you see them but um I try to stay
away from them cuz yeah you know I'm I'm
quick to slap em like that are you
beautiful to see man you see maybe slap
hot dog out [ __ ] I'd send some people
over to that [ __ ] sleepy that if
you ever get hit what is the wildest
thing this is the last person out that
you ever got hit up to do I'm sure a lot
of people would be like hey come do this
come do wrastlin you know I'm saying
come tickle my [ __ ] cousin you know
for 50 thousand you know like a crazy
thing you got invited to go do and
whether you did it or not I had a
opportunity a guy wanted me to [ __ ] his
wife mm-hmm
like literally like the white guy my god
I knew it
[Music]
okay come bang my wife is not a blast
swear to God really oh my god the dark
arts like literally I'm literally we're
playing I think I just hit the game when
he shot in Orlando push the key and
we're in oh yeah we're looking kid get
the [ __ ] pay for fern actually a
$2,000 seat you get [ __ ] Georgia
[ __ ] big baby slap Hut son I'm sorry
but these kids are getting out of hand
you know rise so Wow now these crazy
kids have all the rights kids you're
suing people want to kids are like
leaving home at 15 yes seven I saw some
do to the other day a nine year old just
got a [ __ ] studio apartment near me
can you use the stove there to unplug
his stove that's yeah I'm like what the
[ __ ] man good ass whuppin
I believe in those so what happened
would you say to the guy I was just like
I'm sorry for pushing you and you know
no ha no that husband huh the husband I
don't care about the kid oh you go get
the money or not you didn't oh whoa I
that situation she I'm in Orlando after
the game and I see this woman you know
what I mean and I'm just like she's like
I get back to the bus as soon as I got
it wasn't even like five minutes
Wow DM hey me and my husband you know my
husband I want to [ __ ] you and my
husband wants to watch she's like we'll
pay you $5,000 and how close do you want
to sit did they say or anything no but
you know I wasn't gonna let him sit
close you go out then close enough to
cook a marshmallow in my back you know
you could get this extra good seat right
here
it's a $2,000 seat the chair right here
is a $12,000 sure
did you honor the commitment or no yes I
did yeah yeah and was it were you scared
or not no you know I just do what I do
you know whip it out yeah let's get
ready you know I mean she was already
ready
I wasn't like okay she was you could
tell she was you know wet and juicy you
okay fine no yeah you could just see
like okay she's ready and then I'm
looking at him I'm just kind of like
could you wait for a signal or anything
I'm like looking like over there like
I'm trying to stay focused here try to
see what the [ __ ] he's doing you know
maybe I could see if he's doing what
like videotape and a videotape or what
that was in a rule you can videotape or
anything okay or just like you know you
know touching himself
yeah like hey don't be beating your meat
while I'm getting off right yeah yeah
that's crazy that's insane that's the
craziest thing I ever did and that's
called that's pretty wild
that's pretty busted that's an adventure
though I feel like that's an adventure a
lot of people I feel like kind of dabble
in that sort of world you know we had
somebody one time email offered us 10
grand oh go make love to his wife
somewhere I was trying to broker that
[ __ ] get a little Commission yeah man
he's uh but yeah it's kind of stuff that
happens but yeah so how close did the
guy see it he had he had the 5000 Oh see
okay well this feels like a million
dollar seat to me man I appreciate
thanks so much for coming in man is so
cool bro I was waiting for Big Finish
for so long man
I was waiting so long for this watching
the wing show while you eatin wings and
she really some of her really intense
and some of them are easy to mean for
Louisiana those [ __ ] oh yeah yeah we
watched and I was just like I gotta get
I gotta get with this guy you know see
you know yeah man yeah thank you for
having me yeah thank you guys I'm gonna
and I'm gonna cut off to come on the pot
whenever I'm out there in Vegas and
check it out man you got too many what's
going on and where can people when can
people find the other podcast on the
podcast is about to go up you know we
have Instagram the rabbit and a bear
okay we have websites and stuff like
that we're just trying to get it out
there now so like you know I appreciate
you for showing us some love no man I
appreciate you coming in it's nice to
it's nice to just kind of go through
some of those times when yeah cuz I was
such a fan of my favorite sport in the
whole world as LSU basketball and uh cut
my dad was real old my dad was 70 when I
was born he was an old man and so he and
Dale Brown were friends when he was when
they were young Wow and so we grew up
big fans I just I've always been such a
fan dude so yeah thank you for
entertaining us so much we're a lot of
fun Jabari that dude is hilarious guys
man mm for sure for sure
Glen Davis thanks for being here man
bring up the rabbit and bear which one
are you I'm the
okay after that laughter I don't know if
you move you with the red so you know
this bear like you know to these bear
like there's a good some of these nature
channels they're not really showing
everything thanks for being here
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]